[Music]
when we get pulled over in the back cars
luckily a lot of the police officers
just want their picture taken with it
yes sir you can please do we've created
the back car for the Michael Keaton
Batman movie the mystery machine from
Scooby Doo
everything from Herbie the lovebug to
the land speeder from Star Wars we
create a lot of wild rods out of seat
junk in the past two or three years
we've created 15 16 iconic movie cars I
had a real job at one time in a major
airline we initially started out
refurbishing old cars we decided we're
going to start making some iconic cars
that you could actually get in and out
of it drive it kids can climb on it and
look at it typical bills can be anywhere
from as little as two weeks to as much
as three years the Speed Racer Mach 5
sitting here beside us started off as a
94 Corvette hopefully here in about 30
days it'll be finished up have a great
big honking in on the hood of it it'll
look awesome
there's a tremendous amount of trial and
error a lot of these cars have a lot of
fiberglass on them it's a labor of love
to come out and just continue putting
down layers and layers of fiberglass you
can't go up Oh Riley's our advanced
autoparts and asking for a part for a
back car our Eleanor from Ghana sixty
Seconds car upfront is absolutely a
screen accurate we can get it from the
stainless aluminum interior to the seats
to the shifter the go baby switch in the
center and we drive Eleanor just like
it's supposed to be driven that's why it
was built
[Music]
everything we have we take out and drop
every single piece we take it all to the
local stores we go to McDonald's what
better thing to get throw Suri's into
the back car
[Music]
[Music]
in a world where cat videos and memes
rule the beach one media company will
rise above the noise this is great big
story okay right that's great thank you
got it
yeah that's great cool you can stop
speaking like that now bye what do you
mean this is how I always speak hey my
name is red pepper I'm a voice-over
artist in the UK odd voiced hundreds of
movie trailers men in black saving the
earth from the scum of the universe
leritz project Armageddon Space Jam mr.
Venus holiday so many forget half of
them to be honest with you I started
doing television adverts animations
audiobooks I'll do a lot of video games
as well a lot of them are sound effects
of ghouls in the background when I first
started doing movie traders there was a
that was fun one man coming soon to a
cinema near you or sometimes I do
romantic movies in a sleepy town
sometimes I'm doing hora don't answer
the door you gotta use your voice you
got a reason sometimes and you gotta
take it to the depths very occasionally
I get recognized but generally no but
the time I do get recognized phone goes
off in the Train guaranteed hello and
people look up from behind the
newspapers
the way I got into being a voice artist
was kind of strange are used to drive
trains on the London Underground one
morning I was making my announcements
Harel find the doors a television
executive was a passenger on my train
he got off of the next stop ran up to my
cab
they exchanged details and uh the rest
is history I've had some strange
experiences as a police artist I was
minute rated for Jurassic Park the lost
world Steven Spielberg movie and kindly
they chose me to do the voice in the UK
and something is coming something big as
I said that a voice in my headphones
said wow that's a great voice and I
didn't recognize it was Steven Spielberg
he was listening in from the states into
London will I swore I said Who though is
that everybody went crazy in the studio
no Spielberg Oh sir I appreciate what I
do I'm still meticulous about what I do
I'm so proud of what I do
I really don't look at it as a job I'm
having fun it really is a cool job it's
got to be up there with one of the
coolest jobs on the planet right you got
it true I'm out of here
oh that's a wrap
[Music]
[Music]
my ultimate goal is just to have my name
up there with my dad's name when they're
picking some of the best drivers in the
industry to work on a big car show you
know I don't want to be the best woman
driver the best black woman driver I
want to be the best driver and one of
the best drivers don't get too cocky
because denying of the other work my
name is Brianna Lynch I'm 21 years old
and I've been a stunt driver for four
and a half years my name is Julie Oh J
Lynch I'm her dad and I've been in the
business for 27 years all the dangerous
stuff that the cars are doing in the
movies all the exciting stuff we do that
and not the actors so a couple of the
films that I worked on our Black Panther
Proud Mary Fast and Furious 8 beyonce
music video formation and creep and
that's me and my dad right there I got
started in the business to a New Jack
city I've done all the Fast & Furious
series since number four and Jumanji and
I'm one of the guys up there on the bike
yep that's me right there so cool cuz I
am the coolest well Pfeifer when my dad
and I are working together we actually
like to help each other set the cars up
so when I have to do something like
sliding around the corner my dad is
right there with me trying to make sure
that everything is set up so I think
that's what makes my dad and I really
unique
[Applause]
I got in the stunt driving because of my
dad they taught me how to ride when I
was 3 years old he's been teaching me in
my entire life he's so good at what he
does and so respected in this industry
so since I started son driving he has
been my motivator and my coach my
teacher he's everything but my
accountant pretty much one of the things
that I had learned by riding with her
all the time was that she was able to
handle the pressure 3 2 1 action as much
as people don't believe that you're
inside a car when they explode people
are in those vehicles so it's a lot to
let your kid go and be in danger I guess
part of being a parent and part of being
in the stunt business we do as much as
we can to keep her as safe as possible
and then after that you wish for the
best
I love that I get to share stunt driving
with my dad I think that's a really cool
bond that the two of us have my dad and
I've always been very close he's very
supportive of me chasing down this dream
that I have and if you want to be good
at something you have to put the time in
it's important for you to enjoy your
life and to actually love what you're
doing that's the biggest picture at the
end of the day
[Music]
this story begins in California to be
more specific here in an unspecified
studio lot this is the story of a TV
producer a physicist and the man who
brought them both together that's Wendy
I'm one of the co producers of Marvel's
agent Carter in 2015 ABC released the
show
agent Carter about a secret agent
working in the late 1940s in season two
they debuted a character named Jason
Wilkes Jason is a scientist who works at
isodyne energy and a science character
needs to sound like a real scientist
kind of like this Peggy enters to find
Howard at the chalkboard with books
lambda is animated things constant
divided by MC except we can't calculate
them without an accurate reading of your
mass no mass no wavelength so you need
to write science a dialogue right
sciency stuff on the chalkboard and have
a science e looking lab but you don't
have any science writers on staff no
unfortunately we do not so what did you
do
we called our friends up at the National
Academy of Sciences ID change its Rick
this is Rick hey I'm Rick I work at the
National Academy of Sciences we connect
scientists and engineers with people in
Hollywood people like Wendy yeah we
connected her with Clifford hi my name
is Clifford Johnson I am a professor in
the physics and astronomy department at
USC so it goes like this
Rick pears Clifford with Wendy and they
work together to bring real science into
TV shows yeah yeah yeah for example I
got an email one time saying so how do
you build a
bomb and I had to sort of help them with
that it was a lot of fun Rick's team has
a database with a lot of scientists in
it over 2000 and they've worked on some
major blockbuster films Iron Man 2 and 3
the Avengers age of Ultron a man vs.
Superman star trek into darkness Mission
Impossible five films a narrative have
been inspiring people since the 19th
century to go out and do great things
and build great things we're not trying
to be the accuracy police we're not fact
checkers per se what our goal is is to
inspire more scientists characters and
better science in mainstream media
projects and that's the story about the
hot line for scientists in Hollywood
these changes
[Music]